next week a packed agenda for the
plenary week in Strasbourg let's take a
look at some of the big issues the
burning of virtue Damien pilot is the
latest act of depravity by this
so-called Islamic state has even been
condemned by al-qaeda EU governments are
struggling to find the right response
passenger name record and now to from
text that allows member states to
coordinate border protection to the
latest Tories were called twice a day
terrorism the council and Commission
will give their thoughts and our context
can be used in the future Wednesday and
don't forget that also be escaping are
Isis by the EU foreign representative
federico ma granny on Thursday the
findings were report by the US Senate
haven't shed light on techniques used by
display in the years of following 911
and a big night of the debate over
intelligence gathering a debate that
becomes ever the more important as
member states that to find ways to
counter terrorism waterboarding sleep
deprivation and various forms of
humiliation techniques that US President
Barack Obama said the US would never
resort to again the methods that are
relieved of that tracking down as salman
bin Laden any peace will debate the
report and vote on a resolution on
Wednesday what goes into processed foods
like lasagna spaghetti bolognaise
created quite a storm when you'll
realize that in fact unwittingly with
eating horsemeat the scandal is now well
past its sell-by date but can we trust
our meet so many peas are fallen for the
Commission to re-examine country of
origin labeling and make it compulsory
and processed meat others say it won't
prevent another horse meat type scandal
see how that vote goes on Wednesday and
finally at the plenary mbps will look
into setting up a special committee to
look into the lux leak scandal and also
expect a statement on the ECB's
sling of Greek bonds used as payment for
death unless we have this agenda take
care and enjoy the week